alors comme tout va bien pour vous on va
faire une halte à lui cauchemar en les
bouches mondiale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview cauchemar terrible et vous
allez voir c'est terrible on va
commencer avec les accidents conjugaux
ce qui serait le pire pour vous ça
serait de vous faire surprendre par
votre femme avec votre maîtresse
de surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleur pote
ou de surprendre votre femme notre
maîtresse ensemble
je pense que ça va être mon pote toi
ouais alors si vous surprenez votre
choix serait terrible pour moi je pense
que je vivrai mal quoi ouais je sais où
aller je sais pas et bien justement je
veux pas le savoir le pire cadeau qu'on
pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec jean marie bigard
un concert de chants classiques avec
lambert wilson fait
partie des quais avec
le cancer
pire situation ce serait d'avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu oui parce que la
réunion qu'on s'appelle réunion les
annales zamar zamar mal zamal oui je
fais si j'y retourne faut que je me
mette dans la tête parce que sinon
justement du
polygone dossier qui m'avait appris ça
en fait c'est thierry jean-pierre le
juge jean-pierre il est la réunion de
zamal il m'avait expliqué ça alors donc
pires situations un pétard mais pas de
feu une carte bleue mais pas de code ou
une fille mais pas de préservatif
une fille c'était ça serait terrible moi
je pense ne s'use pas sans cependant non
électriques zermati
déclare alors très très près à vue est
très très préservatif
le pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout
le temps ou un portable qui sonne jamais
j'aurai comme jamais jamais et vous
mais on n'a pas d'amis le pire c'est le
portable lambert wilson bonnes réponses
le pire pour vous ce serait d'être sdf
ou d'habiter dans une maison hantée par
un collant du xviiie siècle du sdf alors
le pire ce serait de connaître à
l'avancé le jour de votre mort ou
d'ignorer que vous êtes atteint d'un mal
incurable
moi je préfère ignorer le 6 mai on est
venus tous atteints d'un mal incurable
va tous mourir de 200 oui c'est vrai
et le ce qui est génial c'est ego sais
pas quand ouais moi si tu me dis c'est
dans une demi heure j'ai peut-être
quitter le plateau pour aller boire une
guerre
pas forcément rester ici
le pire ça serait plus vouloir toucher
votre femme ou plus pouvoir la toucher
plus pouvoir
le pire ça va bientôt être fini
le pire c'est de grandir seul de vivre
seul ou de mourir seul
jeu devrait mourir seul c'est pire ça
moi je prends soin moi je crois que j'ai
vraiment plombé la durance la langue 1g
plombé l'ambiance il faut un petit plus
de la roja il fait un petit coup de la
forêt des marais côtiers
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu